نعرف ولدينا خبره في مجال الاسعافات
الاوليه
[موسيقى]
وطبعا
سيتم استخدام المروحيه
في ايصال الخيم للمناطق النائيه
تركيا طبعا كدوله اصلا
منفتحه
وعلى الخارج طبعا
تلقينا دعما خارجيا
طبعا داخليا نحن متضامنين مع الشعب مع
شعبنا
وايضا اكملنا هذا التضامن مع الدعم الدولي
الذي وصلنا واشكر جميع من السعاده وساهم
في عمليه الانقاذ
هناك رحلات
مجانيه تم توفيرها من قبل الخطوط الجويه
التركيه
وخطوط خطوط بيجاسوس
للطيران وتم نقلهم الى اماكن
امنه وتم توفير اماكن
ومضافات
امنه لهم
[موسيقى]
وايضا
هناك طبعا عمليه اجلاء قام بها او قامت
بها شركات الطيران وصلى عدد الذين تم
اجلائهم مئه الف من قبل شركات الطيران
طبعا رصد الاضرار والمباني المتضرره مهم